so Moore's laws sort of the law of the
computer industry that says compute
power doubles every 24 months or so and
you know that sort of put out there by
experts in technology development as
sort of you know the prototype you know
that's the thing that it really shoot
for Moore's law but nobody ever keeps up
with Moore's law except the computer
industry so it's saying we actually
track and have been tracking really you
know the past 15 years in terms of the
cost for DNA sequencing and trying our
best to keep up with Moore's law and we
actually we actually did keep up with
Moore's law really quite effectively
near the end of the genome project and
even in a number of years about four or
five years after the genome project
using the old-fashioned method that we
used to use for DNA sequencing but we
had sufficiently industrialized those
methods it had actually allowed us to
keep up with Moore's law and then what
happened about 2007 our major groups
switched over to these fancy new methods
they're called next-generation DNA
sequencing methods and almost overnight
and just continued to do it up to the
present time they outstrip Moore's law
by far and it's really been truly
remarkable the cost of DNA sequencing
have plummeted tremendously so that that
first human genome sequence that was
completed ten years ago cost a billion
dollars and now we can sequence a human
genome today in a matter of a day or two
and it costs well under $10,000 really
just a few thousand dollars and if you
follow the curves which we've been
following you can see particularly over
the last six years we have outpaced
Moore's law by far so among the many
exciting developments and genomics
really continues to be new technologies
for sequencing DNA we've come a long way
and have incredibly powerful methods
today but there's new ones coming and we
continue to invest in the development of
new technologies because we see the
importance of it there's a particular
new methodology that's getting a lot of
attention in the genomics community's
days called nanopore sequencing it
really is just these molecules that sit
and lipid bilayers and the strands of
DNA sort of get pulled through it and
literally they're able to detect every
single base on that DNA ladder one at a
time as a
it's pulled through the nanopore it's
just way cool but what's particularly
cool about it is that that technologies
are can be reduced to really small form
and one of the companies that's
manufacturing is releasing an instrument
this year that basically looks like a
USB device in fact it is a USB device
it's a little bit bigger than a thumb
drive and literally it plugs into the
USB port of a laptop computer and I
haven't seen it in I haven't seen it
operate yet but I'm told it can sequence
a human genome and something like a day
well to see when it's released how it
really performs but the notion you know
and whether it's that company and
whether it's this year whether it's
another company that's another year it's
not science fiction to believe that we
will have these little USB devices
sitting in our laptop that can read out
human genome sequences in the next year
or two or three one of the things I
think is particularly cool with this
first company that's launching these USB
devices is that the company tells me
that the USB device that will sequence a
human genome will work equally well in a
PC or a Macintosh computer which makes
me think